- [Narrator] We demand
a lot of our databases,
and our databases demand a lot of us.
They're fragile, expensive,
and tough to maintain.
When things break, it can
be hard to put the pieces
back together at the
speed of your business,
and you often lose data in the process.
We've all come to expect
that distributed databases
can't be globally consistent and scalable.
But what if you didn't
have to make tradeoffs?
What if you could have a
fully managed database service
that's consistent, scales
horizontally across data centers,
and speaks SQL?
This is Cloud Spanner,
a mission critical
relational database service
built from the ground up
and battle tested at Google
for strong consistency
and high availability
at global scale.
At Google, we use Spanner for services
that billions of people access every day.
It's the only cloud service designed
to be a massively distributed
relational database
with transactions and SQL semantics.
And we're talking massive.
Spanner can scale up
to millions of machines
across hundreds of data centers
and trillions of database rows,
stretching across the globe
while behaving like it's all in one place,
where you want it.
We've built Cloud Spanner to
be fully managed and secure.
Automatic sharding and
synchronous replication
with low latency and schema
updates without downtime
means your data is highly
available and reliable.
Instead of endless provisioning
and worrying about maintenance,
you can focus on growing your business.
No matter your needs,
you don't have to hit a wall
with your database service.
Get started with Cloud
Spanner and build what's next.